ragazzi allora oggi vedrete tue partite
del fotone registrati giorni diversi
anche questa inter è citata in un giorno
diverso quindi tre outfit in un video
fantastico contenimento ammazziamo
adotti com'è che adesso faccio un
disastro una donna che faccio un casino
adesso ammazzo tutti quanti mincato mi
viene una somma a donare lista con
l'islam e le sedute le faccio mangiare
prima lo prende a schiaffi
minchia come stai matteo fire vieni qua
ma come cazzo funziona qua mica che ti
ammazzo subito me ne vado così poco
flash
va bene va bene chiama malcore tempo
reale anche la pubblica che non ha tasti
cateria che succede nelle sono sceso
sono delle trivelle che non ci voleva
entrare perché pensavo di morire io
invece non c'è un corpo ovviamente io so
che siamo
no ragazzi a non far votare perché è un
casino jack sia perché quando quando
sono con che sia votano sempre chiamato
rimane il nome d'oro che basta basta
basta
andiamo da sotto io vado con vessicchio
nokia che sta qua si sa viene da me non
venire a me che ti votano tutti vai via
vai via qiao ho paura dell'impostore
sono imposto anche ansia cesca
raga tutto questi veloci questo è niente
no comunque un penetratore la cosa
estranei stato niente niente battere da
caffetteria da navigation vedo baby
basta cosa vuoi da me c'era in alto tipo
quando entri naviganti è rivolto per
adesso vi andò a votare ci frega niente
ma cosa che non ci posso che non vado
fuori verolino per un per un bel in
aspettando radici da allora
io vorrei ammazzare stesso cielo come
bersaglio proprio steve il bersaglio
stessa il bersaglio alla sede di da sola
vediamo
eccola man thor co2 tutti e due non
siamo pazzi siamo pazzi siamo pazzi io
volevo ammazzare charlie e la mazzata
xiaobao beh allora e light ma qualcuno
ha fatto qualcosa qua perché light
fuster martos test ok non so se qualcuno
era in security speroni non è niente e
niente allora allora allora allora ma io
so chi sono gli impostori ma poi mi
odieranno
dillo lì non le sia ma lo sapevo che era
siamo mi insegue ma cosa si chiude le
porte in fa avevamo poi siamo prima da
così ma mi state accusando al caso io mi
fido ma poi se le norme non mi fa però
sempre sito un casinò portomaso primo
secco dal primo secondo chiamate xianbin
[Musica]
assenza la calma e adesso l'unica e
tirare di polemiche dopo dalla signora
cosa fare a famo fix lights e vediamo
chi appare qualcuno nel mentre perché se
c'è il fix lights teoricamente lo
possono chiamare l'emergency però non so
porto vessicchio e l'ho ammazzato io
allora teoricamente adesso basta che
tirino l'emergency ed è finita sentiamo
le emergenze felice se ammazzo qualcuno
nel mentre ho vinto io ok l'unica e
ammazzare che noia e ammazzare che noi a
sette secondi per vincere sei secondi 5
ho vinto forse 4 3 2 1 ho fatto
incredibile
il gip pazzesca dai e vabbè pazzesca con
i suoi morti mi spiego è mai scoperto
pazzesca proprio lui non fa una bella
partita allora gogh onde di subito
allora di qua pecchiamo questo che non è
da far calare ma noi lo chiamiamo se ne
frega allora ragazzi che prima chi sono
i più difficili in assoluto perché c'è
un sacco di gente perché non si capisce
una sega ha notato le luci vediamo se a
passarmi qualcuno vicino qualsiasi
persona essa sia
no le luci danno già l'hanno già fissate
gran partita questa dei ragazzi ragala
sono bravissimi e debbo dire porte sono
andate electrical perché avevo delle
tasche mi è sembrato di vedere il giallo
quindi march utilizzare la botola ha
trovato il corpo pesante giallo march
non parla parla
però quando non parlano vi sentite il
microfono mutato scusate ma non ero in
elettrica raga io ho fatto reattore i
numeri io vincerebbe più per utilizzare
la carta per i con me i numeri fa il
reattore tutta la guarda o gialli
arancioni periodo buddy non c'era un
cadavere quindi la doppia no perché io
mi ero prodotto votata mi dico se la
festa della disperazione una donna che
col a saperlo amava segno io scappato
ragazzi ho veramente schifato mamma mia
ragazzi è partita ce la giochiamo bene e
guarda che secondo me potrebbe essere
buono
oddio oxygen devo beccare qualcuno che
viene suda
la caffetteria ma passerà mai nessuno ac
porco demonio unico che è venuto sulla
caffetteria era era l'impostore io ho
già morto laura allora io ho fatto la
emergency in admin e cera che noi a fare
la tessera l'ho vista e poi sono da fare
quell altra perché nessuno lo stava
facendo e c'era notte morto lì
all'emergency quindi sicuramente che noi
hanno né gli era con fair ed elettrica
va beh questa è una pista che mi devo
dire la cosa allora sono io sono io non
so cosa dirà che non fosse crearmi un
alibi
quindi no ma se mortelli e invece ero io
l'impostore man maggio no ragazzi march
è morto e quindi mi chiedevo fare tutto
da solo
ogni volta che gioco con march devo fare
tutto da solo ogni volta che gioco con
march devo fare tutto march march march
quella che si guarda animarci guardami
vivi porco demonio gioca non posso fare
tu perché mai mi rovini pure a me la rep
mannaggia il marchio guarda se
buongiorno anomico questa a posto devo
ammazzare veramente che noia ragazzi
devo veramente ammazzare che noia
oddio si sono chiuse le porte tutte
aiuto ho chiuso tutte le porte così ve
lo dico urlo mi sono cagato addosso
anch'io
ok per è morta era in coso dove sta non
mi ricordo che si chiama mai con la zona
ancora tutti basso a sinistra vicina
elettrica di a sinistra non vorra in
giro non ho visto niente che mi sono
chiuso tutte le porte addosso no no no
no no aspetta come l'origine ma eravamo
io e visti sono così siamo passati noi è
un istituto ieri scusami io andavo e
roda security andavo di semi sono chiuse
le porte andavo 18 aiutano tutto
riportato credo sia lorenzo c'è per
forza avere sempre m sì perché io
eravamo insieme magari non lo so che
l'ho trovato lì magari morto da due ore
non ho idea
tutti volta che hai visto bene quando è
stato se votate me avete cioè io ho
visto prima lorenzo a fare actor sotto
sono da fa quello sopra è arrivato a
martina
poi dopo si sono chiuse tutte le porte
messo cagato sotto per che marcisce urla
nelle orecchie sono sono sceso sono
sceso e non mi ricordo che mi stavo
dietro ma mi pare martina sound
electrical e paghiamo dal corpo ma avete
visto la proprio nell'angolino incorpora
nell'angolino mi avete guardato bene
stavano andato alla taschino pista 9 non
l'ho vista ciao ragazzi io ho riportato
quello che non so da quanto alla linea
come ricordo scusami sotto di voi due
prima però io non so mai passato disco
mai passato pregava da caso che noi da
sempre abbiamo minuti sempre dai
vessicchio mannaggia elio che valga
momento martina aveva sì che è giusto
con la mia moto a caso l'altro giusto
dichiara innocente perché era scaduto
mannaggia ed i signori pensano le
partite di oggi ci vediamo il bisogno di
amgas fateci sapere se vi è piaciuto sia
certo punto mi piace si chiede a casa un
bel commento e non potendo
allora bel ragazzo
[Musica]